bienvenue chez alphonse mellot 19e du
nom et du prénom vignerons de grand-père
ans petit fils depuis 1513 à sancerre
505 millésimé ce 2018 absolument
exceptionnelle
tout était rentré dans le même dans la
même configuration
rien à faire on attend
tout est parfait et qu'il s'agisse des
rouges ou des blancs on peut commencer à
parler de vendanges du siècle vous
dirait un cadeau du bon dieu
c'est vraiment un très beau cadeau que
vous a fait la vigne cette année moi ça
fait 28 ans que je m'occupe de du
domaine et de faire les 20
moi je n'ai jamais vu une récolte comme
ça on me perds cas encore plus de
bouteille comme moi est pareil n'a
jamais vu ça même constat chez christine
lahlou ato venez 2018 à millésime de
grande qualité et de quantité
donc là on est dans le caveau où on a
nos fut pour mettre les rouges et donc
on a fini en tonnage ce matin donc
jamais 18 donc on devrait en rester là
pendant un an
on va laisser des fermentations
malolactiques se faire à leur rythme
plus qu'à attendre un an pour voir le
résultat de 2018 mais voilà qui est très
prometteur
alors que l'on met en bouteille le 2017
les blonds 2018 sont encore en cubes et
les premières dégustations sont riches
en parfum en sucre et en promesses ouais
ça devrait faire vraiment de très jolies
choses en blanc et en rouge c'est vrai
que cette année c'est sur les millésimes
où on a vraiment des choses magnifiques
quoi les raisins l'état sanitaire était
parfait c'était vraiment une hérédité
mais magnifique du début à la fin des
vendanges qui on dirait quand même assez
longtemps cette année à sancerre le
moral des vignerons et comme le temps au
beau fixe
l'avenir est prometteur le millésime
2018 offre des vins extraordinaire des
rouges a gardé longtemps et c'est ainsi
jusqu'à l'autre bout de la loire